and finally new rule now that we're
starting to see some hope in all this
don't hope shame me you know the problem
with non-stop gloom and doom as it gives
Trump the chance to play the optimist
and optimists tend to win American
elections FDR said the only thing we
have to fear is fear itself you know as
full of [ __ ] as he is I could see Trump
riding that into a second term and then
there will be no hope left for you to
shame so look if this insanity happens
again news sources have to rein it in
everyone knows Corona is no walk in the
park because you literally can't walk in
the park but at some point the daily
drumbeat of depression and terror veers
into panic porn enough with the life
will never be the same headlines and
stop showing us this you know everything
looks scary when you magnified a
thousand times here's a pubic hair boo
last month the Washington Post ran the
headline it feels like a war zone with
this picture this is not a war zone this
is a man with a box of eggs and I've
never seen a war zone with this much
bacon or how about this one horrifying
simulation reveals the dangers of
jogging during the corona virus pandemic
look this virus is easy to catch but if
you can't avoid it jogging you can't
outrun much two weeks ago Inside Edition
said 76,000 in the world had died so
some are making comparisons to the
apocalypse the apocalypse really because
most of us are sitting at home smoking
delivery weed and binge watching a show
about a gay zookeeper unless you're a
frontline health care worker for whom
the phrase above and beyond the call of
duty doesn't even begin to cover it
this is not the apocalypse and I know I
know you expect Inside Edition to be
over the top
but the New York Times they used the
same word last week braced for
apocalyptic surge New York avoids worst
so far and this was an article about how
much better the city was doing than
expected projections had them needing
58,000 hospital beds and it turned out
they needed a quarter of that still bad
but you don't have to put hot sauce on a
jalapeno Jesus sound like Lindsey Graham
talking about Isis when Obama was
president this president needs to rise
to the occasion
before we all get killed back here at
home another recent times headline was
it's terrifying millions more out of
work what the [ __ ] is it's terrifying
doing in a headline granted it's a quote
but who are they quoting Trump pouchy
Stephen King no they're quoting an event
planner in North Hollywood no offense to
the event planners of the world it's
it's amazing what you people can do with
pinecones and silver spray paint but why
are you in my headline how about this
just tell me millions are out of work
without the flashlight under the chin
and I'll decide how I feel about it
there was never headlines like this
before there was no it's terrifying
planes hit World Trade Center
there was no it's sad Titanic sinks
after hitting iceberg or first atomic
bomb dropped
ouch the media also seems obsessed with
finding young people who've died of
Kovan 19 The Washington Post says their
759 under 50 years old horrible of
course then I looked up how many under
50 died of the flu last year almost
3,000 so all this misery from distancing
did some good can I be happy about that
death is terrible of course no matter
how it comes I'm against it and I don't
care who knows it but giving a proper
perspective isn't a cover-up of the
truth it
the truth sudden dramatic deaths like
plane crashes shark attacks tornadoes
mass shootings terrorism awful as they
are kill far less than seasonal flu or
even even hospital-acquired infections
may very well kill more than coronavirus
99 thousand of them last year fifty
thousand died of nephritis every year I
don't even know what that is 22 million
Americans have filed for unemployment
and many will lose their health
insurance studies show lacking health
insurance kills people but it doesn't
lead to pictures like this and it
doesn't happen all at once
we need the news to calm down and treat
us like adults Trump calls you fake news
don't make them be right
you